hello everyone and welcome to a game I
will not describe before showing it to
you as it would just spoil too much fun
it's a game from round five of the
Croatian Grantchester being played in
Zagreb it's shot here Madeira versus
level onion like I said I will not
mention anything about the game but we
can check a few photos so here's a very
nice photo of the five players as we
didn't have a photo challenge in quite
some time now you should be able to name
all these players here without much
trouble as we've seen them so many times
here all five photos are courtesy of
Leonard Otis official photographer of
the Grantchester so there you have it a
nice photo challenge for you and also
here we have as we don't have a photo of
this matchup we do have a nice photo of
lemon onion like we always mentioned he
is well always the most colorful person
in any tournament so there you have it
let's just enjoy that for a second and
now let's enjoy this game or don't
you'll have to decide for ourselves with
d4 by mama DRF and Knight to f6 with c4
e6 nice the c3 and now Bishop to b4
there goes in defense
we have Knight to f3 d5 and now Queen to
a forger forcing Knight to c6 as the
bishop here is under attack with knife
to c6 now blocking check defending the
bishop here and Bishop to g5 bye mama D
ro D captures on c5 and now a3 asking do
you want to move with the bishop do you
want to capture on c3 black captures it
is the the main line B captures and now
Queen to d5 from 11 we have Bishop
character Sun f6g captures on f6 and now
as 11 does have the semi open G file for
attack with
g3 by white with Bishop to d7 preparing
to Castle queenside perhaps also
threatening some nasty discoveries here
so mom Yara has to retreat with the
Queen with Queen to c2 and now Knight to
a5 going for the juicy b3 squared as it
is all wobbly outpost for for black's
knight with E 4 by mama Dee are pushing
back the Queen and now Queen to d6
pressuring the a3 pawn and now comes
Bishop the g2 mama D always ready to
Castle kingside and there is one game in
the database where queen sized
wait here but with Knights to be three
here by Arnon and it is now as of this
moment move 13 that we have a completely
new game so what do you do here your
rope is under attack and you have to
decide what to do if you play something
like rookie - then your rope will be
passive for quite some time now for
example if you push 'if I've white will
have to decide what to do
Black is threatening to open lines and
your king is still in the center you
will most likely have to castle and then
you will have your roof and a - which is
not something you want and Mama Dro
already had his fair share of of passive
positions in this tournament so instead
mahmoud europe after night b3 goes rook
to d1 and here
ahran and says okay that's a that's a
nice pawn just Queen captures on a3 with
castles here queenside castle by Aragon
and now comes Queen to e2 going after
the c4 pawn we have Bishop to b5
defending the pawn and now rook to be
won
so now being the night as the bishop
here is undefended 11 defends it we have
c6 and here comes rook F to D 1 and as
our knob has the past a pond he starts
pushing it with a 5 preparing to move
the Queen and continue pushing his past
pawn probably gonna go some like King c7
put a rope behind a passed pawn as you
should always do and then continue
playing the game and here mom Yara of
course wants to get rid of ordinance
pesky nitin b3 by playing Knights - D -
but he should first prepare it with
Queen to e3 and there's a good reason
why he should prepared with Queen to e3
but he doesn't he plays Knight to d2
without preparing it and now of course
you all see what 11 plays here or if you
don't feel free to pause the video and
try to find this very nice idea what we
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent sacrificer of knights
and for those who just won't enjoy show
Knight captures on d4 it's just a
wonderful idea
Mahmud already gave up the a pond so
level now says ok I will give you the
night for 2 more points and I have 4
points I'm ready to push on the Queen
side and you have no points to oppose
them which is which is pretty much
insane we've see captures on d4 rook
captures on d4 and now what do you play
here black
has these four lovely pawns that he's
ready to push and you have to create
some sort of a defense we have looked to
a1 first attacking the Queen and now
Queen to be to mom Yara also could have
gone for Queen to b4 because now rook b1
doesn't really push away the Queen
you're just gonna play c3 attack the
knight attack the Queen and black is
just perfectly fine here I mean black is
winning here in this position but Arjun
played Queen to b2 also a very nice move
now comes Luke a2 b1 and now he plays C
3 attack in the night defending the
Queen also attacking the Queen with the
bishop here we have Queen to f3 and now
again you're playing black here feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best continuation for for black here
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player of games that were not described
at the beginning of the video and for
those of you just wanna enjoy the show
rook captures and d2 and now what can
black what can white play here other
than capturing the Queen there isn't a
good move here you have to capture the
Queen otherwise you're just worse and
well you can just we basically have to
pretend here that this is exactly what
you want it and you have to capture the
Queen so we have rook captures on B to C
capture son b2 and now Bishop the f1 you
can't really capture the rook otherwise
black gets another Queen into the game
so here we have Bishop to f1 opposing
the very strong leadership on b5 but
this also doesn't work unfortunately for
mommy tiara so feel free to pause the
video yet again and try to find I'm just
gonna call it the insta kill here and
feel free to finish the game with black
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you're just an awesome
player and for those who just wanna
enjoy show Bishop to e2 this is the move
that ends the game on the spot as here
you don't really have all that much to
do if you capture the bishop I mean
you're a white queen and look around or
attack if you capture the bishop
you just get rook captures here with
Czech Bishop captures and you get
another Queen into the game and now you
have a rook and the Queen against Bishop
and Queen but you have
I mean so many points here even three
3-connected passed pawns on the
queenside
of course completely winning for black
and on the other hand after Bishop to e2
if you don't capture it you might try
something like rook captures here give
up the Queen and go into an endgame
still doesn't work Bishop captures you
will grab this very dangerous pawn but
after Bishop captures here white black
is just up for points and of course it's
completely winning endgame for black so
here after Bishop to f1 Bishop to e2
wins the game for 11 but he didn't play
it
he played rook H to d8 which isn't all
that big of a deal it's not like xi is
unable to find Bishop to e2 he just
found Luke to d8 first he saw that it
was leading to a win and he didn't
really care about you know trying
something else if you have a sure thing
you're not gonna be you know trying to
spot hidden beauties in the position but
okay here rook the b1 now mama DRF gets
you know new wind in his back so to say
and now again what do you play here
again Bishop to d3 a very strong move as
it attacks the rook you force the rook
to move and then you're gonna promote
your pawn or you force white to capture
and then half after rook captures you
just have a very strong position here
the Queen has to move you can go rook c3
rook here and it's just just and game
over
but again xi chooses a different align
with Bishop captures King captures and
now he goes rook the C to rook to c2
doesn't work here what xi should have
gone for is again this rooked d3 because
now why it has to move the Queen and now
after you move the Queen now you don't
go rook c3 not this time because in d1
well what you can do is just push a 4
and there's nothing or what can do
against a 3 and a 2
it's just another another nice game over
so after King captures on f-111 did a
different movie played rook to c2 he
thought okay the game's over I'm just
gonna play rook c1 check and the game
the game ends so he didn't really look
for anything else and during all of
these positions Levin had more than an
hour of time on his clock so if he used
some of it he would have found
everything but he just pretty much
played instantly and he was slowly but
surely kept ruining his position here
mama Dara played King to g2 and now you
no longer have rooks
one because it's not check you're just
gonna lose your pawn here so okay mommy
you're 11 goes rook d2 d2
now with something with a lot of threats
here the Queen cannot noise we're gonna
capture here and now you're threatening
to start pushing your pawn here but
mommy arrow also gets a say in this we
have Queen captures on f6 and now comes
a four so what do you do here
King to h3 and it seems that it will be
very hard to find a win for black now or
maybe not but we'll have to see what
happens here mommy Arif has to decide
what to play here first we have rook
captures on f2 which is of course the
best move in the position and here we
have Queen to h8 check by mama D of the
best move for white that ensured a draw
was Queen to e7 because you're keeping
an eye on a3 you're not allowing black
to push it and you're also threatening a
lot of Perpetual here in this position
what okay mom Dara went for Queen to HH
check with King to c7 and now he played
Queen back to d4 and again it's not not
great as it was a move a movable where
mother had this Queen to e7 move here
again we have a very dangerous position
where black can play a lot of moves for
example he can play a three but a3 isn't
all that great
yes you are threatening a two but after
Queen to a7 you're not really
threatening a - there's no way for you
to ever push this and after King
captures here sort of rook a person H to
get King g4 and now after f6 trying to
keep the King away you will just get
Queen to a5 check and you enter a series
of Perpetual as you don't really you
don't really get a say in this if you go
here then it's just a queen d8 check
followed by Queen a5 check Queen D a
check Queen a5 check a perpetual and if
you touch the D line for example if you
go King b6 then Ruby do one check just
wins for white as now the Queen and the
rook control the d2 scores so black
cannot block with the rope you're gonna
have to go up the board and then this
will just be made Queen c7 check you
have to move the King either way and
this will be checkmate so this doesn't
work but there is another move that
works I would ask you to find it but you
already saw the arrow so it would be it
would be weird if I asked you to do it
but b5 actually
continues to win the game for 411
because here but it's again a very hard
choice to make but not a such a hard
choice when you have so much time on the
clock here you have to calculate it
after Queen a7 check King d6 King to g4
you don't want to allow this to come
with check and you don't want while
their King is still on h3 for black to
trap you here with h5 kink the e5 now
and here you have to see that after a
couple of checks King before 26 check
you're gonna go King to c3 Queen e5
check King b3 there are no more checks
black can just play a3 a2 and win the
game so this was the way to go for 11
but 11 plays f6 now he doesn't want to
allow this Queen to e5 check and now he
wants to checkmate mama door he wants to
play h5 prevent the King from reaching
g4 and deliver mate rook captures and h2
will be checkmate
but now mama Derek just played the Queen
captures an a4 and now what do you play
here the problem now with h5 is that it
doesn't work after h5 mama drf has Queen
8 5 check and we again enter this line
of the perpetual that we already
explained if you go King b8 then again
Queen da to check followed by Queen
eight five two Queen DHA Queen a5 check
if you go King to see it it's a similar
Queen eight eight check and now you
either have to go I mean you have to go
to c7 you cannot touch the D line if you
go King c7 again Queen a5 check King to
c8 you will go here and then after King
b7 check we just repeat or if you try
something like King d7 then rogue d1
again a possibility because now after
you block yes now you can block but now
comes Luke captures and after rook
captures Queen captures in b7 with check
and you prevent the pond from queening
yet again so here after Queen captures
on a 411 doesn't really have a good
continuation here h5 simply doesn't work
you are not promoting your pawn and the
white is just threatening so many
Perpetual salt Levin played rook
captures on h2 we have King to g4 and
now h5 with check with King to f4 and
now comes Luke H 2 f2 with check King to
e3 we look after eating with check King
to f3 and here we just have look after
checking III rook Fe to check key of 3
and after rook after
it was in this position that 11 Arlen
and shot him I'm not resigned but drew
their game which is really amazing it
was a Gary Kasparov had an interview
during the Grantchester and he said that
well he he liked all the games of course
but that 11 had to work extremely hard
in this game to not win it which is I'm
sure that when I asked you in this
position let me just go through it
King captures here before the trade of
the bishops when I asked you to find the
best move in this position that many of
you found of course Bishop to e2 it's
not I mean it's in the position everyone
will find it and of course if 11 spent a
minute on it or even 30 seconds probably
he would have found it but first he
continued with a weaker move and then
four or four or five turns in a row he
played a weak remove and all of a sudden
Mammadov equalized and there was no way
back which is really a shame as this is
really a beauty I mean first Mahmud art
of playing actively not not a bad idea
giving up the the a pawn but then
allowing 11 to capture the two points
with the night and then he had so many
past pawns on the Queen side I was just
it was just beautiful and for to ruin it
in such a way is just well it's just sad
but it still is a very nice game I don't
know who sat her here mom Yara for again
playing a really weird game or 11 who
really had a chance to get up the up the
rankings in the tournament but he messed
up but either way that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it especially all the
niceties that weren't played in the game
I would like to thank Mark Boudreau is
Jesper Hodge Carroll Krinsky
Phillip messiah's and and Edie for Malta
for a conversion to my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos you're thankful for watching and
I will see you soon
well you know you know how it goes thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day